[Musique]
nous allons passer madame si vous le
voulez bien à la séquence suivante
et alors je veux dire que c'est un effet
du hasard de l'actualité je vous jure
qu'elle équipe de c'est-à-dire n'a rien
fait pour combiner entre guillemets
cette rencontre mais je trouve que une
des deux personnes auprès de guy maddin
b va se retrouver notre grand témoin va
se retrouver et une amie et je passe
d'enfance de madame b alors de retrouver
une camarade de déportation lorsque vous
voyez marceline loridan et avant de
passer à la séquence suivante ça vous
rappelle un certain nombre de choses
importantes qui sont passés dans votre
vie et vous êtes resté en contact étroit
très étroit oui je pense que c'est une
chose suffisamment dur et après tout qui
est absolument pas utile d'évoquer
j'aurais bien aimé entendre ce
tutoiement quand même mais pas mal face
à twente
non je peux lui demander tu vas bien
alors je vais
[Musique]